I don't know what it's going to take for
the legislature to understand this I
hate to have one of their family members
be killed by a DUI driver and that's
what finally tips the hand for us to get
some help and it shouldn't take that
the union representing Nevada state
troopers warning lawmakers have to do
something before there's no one
patrolling our roadways last night at 11
our a news now investigators showed you
how the Staffing crisis is leading to
delays when there's an emergency well
now we have the the reason why eight
news now investigator David charns with
the startling number of how much our
troopers make compared to other police
departments David well department
leaders say some new Troopers will go
through the State Police Academy only to
jump over to another department and make
more money tonight the union
representing these police officers says
a handful just left or are planning to
leave
we're in Las Vegas Nevada 24 7 drinking
town this isn't another town across
country that shuts down at 10 o'clock at
night it's constant a constant battle
between State Police patrolling our
roads and the impaired and reckless
drivers creating havoc on them Wayne
dice is a spokesman for the Nevada
police Union it's really bad right now
it's because of a lack of enforcement
and we can't do any proactive
enforcement because we don't have enough
Personnel to do that as the 8 news now
investigators reported Monday data from
the Department of Public Safety reveals
a 32 percent vacancy rate for sworn
officers out of 389 positions
123 need to be filled there are some
parts of Nevada with no coverage the
deputy director of the department saying
this just days ago if we can't start
stopping the bleeding this year we're
not sure we'll be around by next year
here's the big reason why data the 8
news now investigators obtained shows a
starting state trooper will make about
21 dollars an hour compare that to the
average of about twenty six dollars for
all other Nevada agencies combined a 24
difference totaling more than ten
thousand dollars a year retired Colonel
and Carpenter is the former head of
Highway Patrol I can't see
how the state of Nevada goes forward
without paying these people what they're
worth I just don't understand they'll
just keep leaving and then there's this
department data revealing a State
Trooper could make four hundred thousand
dollars less than their Metro
counterpart over a 20-year career do you
feel like people were even listening to
you you know I think they listened I
think it's difficult because the state
has a finite amount of money department
leaders estimate Governor Joe Lombardo's
proposal to raise salaries would be at
18 net gain for one year but starting in
July the same group of people will have
to contribute 30 percent of their
paychecks to retirement our goal would
be to get the pay up to 25 increase just
so we can start on the same footing as
everybody else it's not enough it's not
acceptable
now the governor is proposing pay
increases over the next two years for
all state employees but we have yet to
see a copy of that official proposal
that of course will have to make its way
through the legislature I'm David charns
8 News Now